hey everyone diavolo here and welcome to
my second jiu-jitsu kaizen character
showcase in each video we will go over a
different character their abilities and
their history in the juju sukhasan
universe
so brace yourself as there are some
spoilers that come later on in the video
but do not worry as i'll give a warning
when they come up if new around here be
sure to subscribe for similar content
and if you do enjoy the video feel free
to hit but that like button hope you
guys all enjoy the video
now let's get into it introduction and
facts
today we are going to go over the
abilities and history of kentucky who in
my opinion
is one of the coolest juju kaizen
characters that i've seen so far in the
series nami is one of the most relatable
people in the series for people in the
everyday grind doing 40 plus hours a
week who hate the idea of having to work
overtime
and one of his curse abilities
personifies that fact but we'll get to
that in a bit
first a little bit about nanami we are
first introduced to him
in episode 8 of the anime and chapter 18
of the manga he is 27 years old
has danish ancestry and is 184
centimeters tall with brownie blonde
flowing here he currently works at tokyo
metropolitan curse technical college as
he used to work in an office
nanami is usually fully dressed in a
clean tan
suit with a white dress shirt and his
signature shades
after he graduated from jiu jitsu
technical school he wore a vertical
striped jacket over a white button-down
shirt and a colored tie with dots all
over it vertically striped pants
and black shoes nanami is extremely
intelligent and reserved at the same
time and he seems to be very serious
about his work yet he only says that he
is a jujutsu sorcerer because it is
slightly less
mind-numbing than a regular career
though he appears to be very stoic and
tough on the outside beneath his hard
shell he is a kind man with good moral
values and is just like everyone else
worn down by the mundane way of life and
wishes that he could just get back some
of the younger days that he lost
that's why i think he treats yuji like a
kid and he doesn't want to see him just
throw away his use for the sake of
becoming a jujutsu sorcerer
the reason he decided to leave the rat
race being an office worker was because
like most people he felt like no one
ever cared about his work and it never
had an
impact on anyone else whereas before the
office life as a sorcerer he got small
pieces of appreciation from innocent
people
even if it was only a little it was more
than enough to come back to being a
sorcerer and live his life without
regrets
the abilities of nanami kinter
nanami is a grade one sorcerer and is
considered to be among the top class of
sorcerers at
jujutsu high he carries a huge amount of
respect from the other high-level
sorcerers and gojo even
hand-picked nami to help mentor yuji
nanami is a master swordsman even though
his wrapped blade may look
extremely short it is considered to be a
sword he is extremely proficient with it
when it comes to his curse technique
nanami is an extremely tactical and
technical fighter who plans on using
every possible moment
of the fight to his advantage so that he
can exploit his enemies
he never misses his target's weakest
points when it is posed by his curse
technique ratio which helps him wear
down his enemies
proficiently nanami appears to have a
high amount of cursed energy that he is
able to control through his cursed
technique with great efficiency he has
precise control over his curse energy to
the point that he even subconsciously
protects his soul with it something that
was revealed when mojito tried to
reshape his soul with idol
transfiguration in their fight
through the use of cursed energy
manipulation naomi has the ability to
use black flash
using cocusin i don't know how to say it
exactly but yeah
a technique that creates spatial
distortion when a user connects
with an impact of cursed energy within a
span of 0.0001 seconds or a physical
hit this causes the cursed energy to
flash back
creating a normal attack 2.5 to the
power of whatever
normal punches he used to be the record
holder of most consecutive uses of black
flash
until ug4 hanami using five black
flashes i'm pretty sure i think it was
five was either four and he tied with
an army binding valves are considered by
all
curse energy users to be one of the
essentials of jujutsu sorcery
they are essentially contracts created
through curse energy that an individual
can make with oneself or another person
nami kintu has two binding vowels which
are showing one's card and overtime
showing one's card is a commonly used
binding vowel by many jiu jitsu
practitioners by telling the enemy
directly how his curse technique works
nanami can maximize the output of his
next attack
over time which is my personal favorite
ability in the series so far is nanami's
signature binding vow with himself
nanami limits the amount of cursed
energy he can utilize
during the time he's officially on the
clock working for jujutsu high kind of
like anyone who's working a long ass day
and plans to meet a lovely lady
afterwards they need to save their
important amount of energy
so that they can get done when it
really matters once he goes beyond his
normal shift he gets pissed and his tyre
comes off which i'm pretty sure is like
a constrictor of energy or something he
wraps it around his fists and over time
hours begin
nanami's cursed energy swells to a great
degree and grants him a boost in
fighting power allowing him to quickly
deal with enemies like we saw with
mojito and the sewer
nanami also has two innate techniques
which are ratio and collapse
we see both of these techniques used in
episode 10 and 11 of
fight with mojito ratio technique is an
army's innate technique that can divide
his target with 10 lines and forcibly
create a weak spot at the ratio point of
seven to three the target's lines don't
have to match up with the target's
length or wingspan now nami can
freely choose which parts to divide
including the subject's head
torso arms and legs this technique also
works on non-living objects
flaps is an expanded curse technique
that creates a large weak point in the
surrounding environment
allowing nanami to destroy it with a
single blow this compared with his
constant adaption to the environment and
the enemies he is fighting allows him to
inflict an extreme amount of damage and
can create easy escape routes when he is
fighting and finds himself in a tight
spot nami first used this technique
after unleashing both his spinning
vowels
in order to destroy the underground
tunnel and trap mojito
that now brings all of nanami kinto's
abilities to an end for anyone watching
this is just a quick warning that there
are spoilers coming up from this point
onwards so just watch out as the story
or parts of it may be spoiled for you
the history of nanami kentucky
technical college during his first year
he teamed up with you high barter i
don't know how to say his last name
uh excuse me for this you have a mission
that was supposed to be exercising a
second grade curse
nami remarked that it was a pretty
difficult mission for two first graders
the mission turned out to be more
difficult than they imagined
sadly you was killed and the cursed
spirit was more than tough enough to be
able to go up against first grace
sorcerers an
army is in the morgue while ghetto is
examining you's dead body and he
explains how the mission was botched and
much more difficult than he realized
after graduating from the college he
decided to leave the life of a sorcerer
and become
a celery man so i don't know what
happened from here but for some reason
my microphone decided to go and do the
old fuckerooni and uh well yeah so it
sounds slightly different from here but
i i really don't know why sorry about
this guys anyway continuing
nanami along with yuji investigate the
theatre incident where nanami manages to
teach yuji to see
remnants as they follow the remnants
nami and yuji talk about how they may be
a witness to the murder
after following the remnants the two
come across two cursed spirits and each
take on one nani begins to explain how
his technique works and shows
yuji how it works nanami then watches
yuji and figures out how yuji's
technique works
he notices that there is something wrong
with the cursed spirits and stops yuji
from killing his cursed spirit an army
has the cursed spirits examined by shoko
which reveals that the cursed spirits
were once human after finding this out
the two head out to continue
investigating after
finding out that there have been
multiple missing person reports
and mysterious deaths nanami decides to
have yuji investigate juniper while he
follows up a different lead
nanami heads into the sewers where he
comes into contact with mahiso he begins
to fight against mojito
and plans to finish the fight quickly
since he doesn't like to work overtime
because nanami manages to break nahido's
arm
mojito stops fighting to explain how his
technique works and heals his arm
as mojito wonders what would happen if
he used this technique on a sorcerer
then army simply looks at his watch and
says that he will finish this by 6.
an army continues to fight mohito which
results in bajito injuring an army once
it hits six o'clock nanami wraps his tie
around his hand and starts to explain
how his technique works
nanami then uses this technique on a
wall so that a large amount of rubble
falls on top of them
as mojito watches the rubble nami uses
his technique to injure his leg
and retreats afterwards nanami contacts
kiyotaka and reveals to him what had
happened
after hanging up nanami thinks about
what kind of character he is
later yuji finds out what happened to
nanami and asks nanami to take him next
time nanami explains how it is not
necessary
and asks yuji to continue investigating
and observing
juniper the next day nanami is handling
mojito's cursed spirits in the sewer
with ino
an army contacts yuji about not heading
to unipea's school
he then leaves eno to handle the
creatures as he thinks that yuji will
most likely head to the school anyway
he manages to show up and defends yuji
when mojito is about to land a blow on
yuji nanami
asks about the situation and yuji
reveals everything that has happened
after finding out that yushi can harm
mojito nanami has yuchi fight mojito
with him as nanami and yuji battle
against mojito
he decides to change tactics and have
his cursed spirits attack yuji nanami
fights against mojito but mojito manages
to restrain an army
as mohito goes to finish him off yuji
shows up and frees him
nanami and yuji continue to overwhelm
mojito until mojito uses his territorial
expansion to trap nanami nanami thinks
about the situation he is in
and comes to the conclusion that he is
in the palm of mojito's hand he prepares
to take off mojito since he has no
regrets but yuji shows up and sakuna
wounds mojito causing the territorial
expansion to be undone he notices that
yuji is laying on the ground and goes to
check up on him later that day
nanami meets with yuji and they talk
about the situation that had just
happened
the shibuya incident arc on the 31st of
october nanami is with megami and takuma
at shibuya station near exit 13 when
they are informed about the situation in
shibuya as takuma starts to tell megami
everything about the curtain the nami
tells tikami that megami already knows
all of this stuff and needs to stop
trying to impress him nanami then
wonders where gojo is
later when the citizens in the screen
are attacked by mutated humans nanami
along with megami and takuma head into
the screen to protect the people while
heading into the screen an army and
megami discuss
why mutated humans are attacking now and
how nanami will head towards the enemy
responsible for the screen while megami
and takuma do their best to rescue the
people
when yuji calls out to nanami and
announces what has happened to gojo
nanami tells megami and takuma that they
will be heading towards yuji's location
once they reach yuji's location koichi
explains what happened to them
and what's the best course of action
that should be taken nanami agrees with
koichi's plan and says that they will
first need to lift the screen
around shibuya nami says that he will go
meet up with kiyotaka
whilst megami yuji and takuma deal with
the screens he tells takuma that he is
in charge and that they should explain
the situation to noah bata and natsuya
if they meet with him an army then
leaves to meet up with kiyotaka
later nanami finds kiyotaka laying on
the ground wounded after finding
kiyataka in that state an army gets
angry and heads out
he then comes across nevada and the
enemy that are attacking the assistant
directors
nami starts walking towards the enemy
and they try to get him to stop but
notices that their hostages have left
when an army gets close to the enemy the
enemy attacks him but notices that none
of his attacks are working nanami asks
the enemy how many and where his allies
are
the enemy says that he doesn't know and
nani sends him flying into a wall
as the enemy gets up nanami grabs him
and asks him again
the enemy says that he doesn't know
which nanami hits him again when the
enemy tries to have his sword attack
from behind nabarro saves nanami
as the enemy is angered at nabarro
nanami grabs the enemy and asks him
if he is the one that killed all the
assistant managers when the enemy
apologizes nanami sends the enemy flying
through a building
after this he explains to akari and
nobara the situation with yotaka and how
gojo has been sealed the nami then says
that he will be going to help gojo which
nibara says that she wants to join him
but nanami says that this upcoming fight
is for grade one sorcerers and that she
would only get in the way nanami tells
the two to stay here while he leaves to
help gojo
nanami manages to encounter maki and
naobata and joins them as they
enter the shibuya station when three
come across a cursed
spirit nanami says that he will deal
with the spirit but naobarta steps in
an army then watches as naobaota fights
the cursed spirit when neobata manages
to distract the cursed spirit
dig on nanami along with maki join in
and attack him dagon manages to defend
itself however
nami notes how strong dagon is and how
large amount of hp he has
when naobasa manages to figure out how
dagon is defending herself nanami and
the other two
attack dig on speed-based attacks and
dagon is forced to retreat
dagon manages to trap nanami along with
naobito and maki in his domain expansion
and nanami is instantly hit with the
domain's shorehit technique
when dagon uses his death swarm attack
nanami advises maki on how to survive it
before he is engulfed by multiple fish
nanami manages to survive the attack and
defends megami while megami opens up an
exit for them to flee
when megami manages to create an exit
nanami gives the signal
to retreat but they are shocked when
toji comes through the portal after
tochi comes
through the portal an army asks about
the portal but megami says
that the portal has closed he then
watches as toji takes on dagon
while watching nanami asks megami if he
can last for a little while longer
and watch megamere replies that he can
when toji exercises dekon nanami thinks
about how they only survive because toji
had arrived but also wonders if toji is
on his side
toji suddenly takes megami to another
location but nanami is more concerned
about the arrival of joker since jogo
was stronger than dig on nanami is then
easily taken out by jo-go and burnt to a
crisp
an army manages to get out but is
severely wounded and burned and on the
brink of death but continues onward
regardless
when an army comes across a large amount
of mutated humans the nami thinks about
how he could spend his time living in
malaysia
relaxing and chilling out since he's so
damn tired now
nami then worries about maki megami and
albata
and wonders what happened to them nanami
then takes on
the mutated humans and is confronted by
mojito the two have
a small chair and an army wonders what
he is trying to do suddenly he sees
hayabada who points to his right nanami
turns to see yuji
he then tells yuchi that he's got it
from here as mojito lands his hand
on nanami's chest and evaporates them
so uh yeah it was kind of a kind of a
sad story for
for nanami coming to an end his life and
all that awesome character and i
loved him to bert's real sad to see him
die like in the last few chapters
of the uh shibuya arc but you know you
can't do much about that
so that brings the history and abilities
of nanami kento to an end
if you did enjoy the video be sure to
headbutt the out of that like
button and if you are new around here be
sure to subscribe for similar content i
hope you all enjoy the video if you
would like to see more about a specific
character like ghetto or gojo leave a
comment down below letting me know with
who you'd like me to go over next but
for now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo hope you all enjoy
the video and i'll see you guys in my
next
jujutsu kaizen character showcase bye
you